all right so I can't talk about aliens
and strange bloops and skeptics and all
that stuff without talking about some
movies because I think my whole my whole
ethos on this was built basically by
science-fiction movies and I've seen
pretty much everyone that people talk
about as being things that defined them
what's it for me well for me my defining
sci-fi movie was contact which was
written by Carl Sagan it was his only
non-fiction book no his only fiction
books are nonfiction fiction nonfiction
I'm not sure it was only it was his only
fiction book he of course was a great
scientist and he was really neil
degrasse tyson before he was that movie
i actually went to see i had eaten pot
brownies and i was going to see boogie
nights and it was sold out and i ended
up in contact oh you've no idea what man
i mean it it literally blew my mind it
changed everything that I think and I
think contact is sort of exactly what
you're talking about with a lot of this
stuff this sort of subtle knowing of
contact but not they're not going to
necessarily like the prime directive you
know with Star Trek which I'm not a big
fan of my friend is a Eugene Roddenberry
so you know the idea of non-interference
you know this is this is very possible
now interestingly enough about contact
one of the characters in contact was the
bald guy that was up in orbit because he
had cancer yeah that guy was modeled
after a really amazing business tycoon
named Robert Bigelow you might know his
name because Bigelow right now currently
has two personal orbiting space habitats
he got the contract to put the
inflatables onto the ISS and what
colonize or mind the moon right this is
Robert Bigelow so this movie you're
talking about was not far from reality
yeah in the sense that they're dealing
with real people with real ideas so just
look at that equation for say well
that's that's why I love contact because
it was written by Carl Sagan he's a
master at explaining science and this
was his way of sort of like with a game
now it palatable so interstellar so
let's talk about that for a little bit
cuz that's another I loved it because it
felt like this stuff is kind of real
it's close yeah like we're exploring the
universe man we're talking literally
about mining the moon and colonizing
Mars nobody laughs at that anymore
I mean this is a specie leaving moving
offworld and starting to touch and
engage the outside environment if not
live there I mean it is absolutely
fascinating this is real life real world
is happening now right so doesn't some
of this go to what we were talking about
in the previous segment which is sort of
the avatar idea that we're gonna wreck
this planet and then we're gonna have to
go somewhere else and then that's where
the really interesting stuff happens
because then we are potentially the
invaders of another planet and another
species I don't want to be a pessimist I
think human beings are doing pretty darn
well we have our issues but you know I
think that we're also problem solvers so
I am an optimist in this sense I think
true exploration is gonna come from from
a wealth of economy a wealth of
curiosity I don't think that if we're
having so many bad problems on earth
that we're gonna naturally say let's go
somewhere else right that if we thrive
here we can explore there so we have to
keep it tighter in home right and in
order to do that so I think it's a it's
a reflection of a great society if you
can reach out to the stars
right so jumping back to interstellar
first yes because there was a lot there
how much of this do you think will be
related to time-travel with that
continue can really you cannot separate
them because the way that these crafts
allegedly you know travel or traverse
space time is by distorting gravity so
the classic example is a gravity wave
amplifier the idea that if you can
distort with high energy space-time in
front of you you are a time traveler by
being a space traveler right so this is
that was sort of an interstellar like
that's the best that can make your brain
explode it's one thing to be like that
we go to other planets maybe some aliens
but this other piece of people aging
differently and all that stuff right it
just it's the basic idea is that time
itself is a fabric it can be folded it
can be bent so that's why when they got
near the black hole
all of a sudden time shifted for the
different you know sets of people where
they were because the gravity it's
gravity gravity is what warps space or
space-time simple right so okay I've
answered the question of my favorite
sci-fi movie oh gosh et I mean that
seems right there's a there's a
a lien it's hidden not hidden there's
probably bad aliens there's probably
good aliens there's good people there's
bad people I mean you know I just
thought he was cute yeah